Defining methods is a handy way
to add custom functionality in
any programming language.
But writing methods for
everything doesn't scale very well.
How can you guarantee that you'll only
call a method like drink water from
bowl, using a dog hash as your argument?
Probably isn't a great idea to
let your users pass the string,
fire extinguisher, to that method.
This method only really makes sense for
dogs.
So what if instead of
representing our dog as a hash
we create its own data structure.
A dog data structure which
we'll call a dog object.
Much like a string or an array or
a symbol this dog object
can have its own methods.
This dog might be able to bark,
wag its tail or drink from the bowl.
This is a bit of a tricky concept
to wrap your head around at first.
When I first started teaching myself to
code using online tutorials, this was
often the point when I would just
throw my hands up and say that's it.
I'm done.
So if you get frustrated or feel like
this isn't coming quite naturally as
the prior content, don't worry.
Instead, lean on the community
resources we have available to you
until it clicks.
That moment, that aha moment,
will make everything worth it.